good day and welcome everyone i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and please allow
me to welcome you to this edition of our 2020
2021 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture is supported
by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
it is my pleasure today and privilege to welcome
dr daniel gardner professor of physiology and
biophysics from wild cornell medical school in
new york city dan gardner has cultivated a very
impressive career serving as the head of the
laboratory of neuroinformatics and as professor
of physiology and biophysics at weill cornell for
many years now he has made enormous contributions
to the synaptic biophysics underpinning networks
of neurons in eplasia delivered resources for the
exchange of neuroscientific data and examine the
parallels between biological and artificial neural
networks he and members of his laboratory like to
ask the big questions such as our neural circuits
and the computations they perform evolutionary
conserved the answers to such questions
may be simplified as analyses of multi-neuron
recording and inform new neuromorphic designs for
future artificial intelligence systems dr gardner
examines new approaches to explore this question
including projected neuromorphic neural
networks or n-cubed collaborative as well as
something called the next cool virtual meeting
which i'm really interested to hear about dan
he has received numerous research accolades
and research support from federal agencies
such as the national institutes of health
making vital contributions under for example
the united states human brain project um that was
uh took place during the decade of the brain um
as which is a kind of a precursor to the brain
initiative today as well as to the european
brain project today's presentation from dan is
entitled do biological neural networks perform
identifiable and verifiable canonical computations
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube if you are watching via
youtube thank you so much for joining us today and
also our specially selected 2020 2021 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for dr gardner
via the chat feature of their zoom sessions i will
synthesize these questions and ask them on
your behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that welcome dan thank
you so much we are really excited to hear your
lecture today and professor van horn requested a
football an analog so uh the uva quarterback fades
back throws and it's intercepted by the big red
cornell now has the ball all right enough of the
football analog now i'm going to be asking this
question but i'm not going to be answering yet
so i'm going to propose this neuromorphic neural
network's viewpoint and neuromorphic neural
networks with the three n's gives us the logo that
you can see on the right called encubed the ideas
behind this come from a very very large number
of colleagues at many many institutions over
many many years too many to thank individually
but i especially want to thank chuck stevens
who's been inspiring me since 1971 and among the
many people i said who thought about this question
including chuck uh well we had a bunch of us about
25 30 years ago now and what we thought about it
and what resulted from it is no k noted on some of
the following slides and it's expanded later but
first we have a mandatory disclosure statement
my money comes only from federal grants i'm a
consultant occasionally to places in the u.s
and the uk but i do get significant income uh
from these books for instance the principles of
neuroscience edited by candelanar i get 25 cents
anytime one of you buys a copy so i'm shamelessly
going to be plugging this book throughout the uh
the talk but the real self-serving motivation
not financial is to encourage people in the data
sciences in computational neuroscience and in
the machine learning communities to think about
the question of what computations are actually
being performed by biological neural networks
it's an interesting question to which we don't
have an immediate answer i'm going to begin with
a personal history of neural networks and what
they've meant to me which gives you a sense about
why i've been thinking about this problem for so
long artificial neural networks for those of you
who don't work in the field were first proposed
in ancient times in the 1940s before people knew
really anything about how neurons and synapses
work and they were model objects that had some
of the properties that people thought neurons
had they were a little bit like logic gates that
were on or off and had multiple inputs and the
field didn't go very well with the failure of
what were called perceptrons which it turned out
couldn't solve some simple basic problems but then
in a classical past that was more recent
than that starting in the 1960s these were
made a little bit more neuromorphic especially as
layering became possible and an artificial neural
neck that net didn't have just one or two layers
but multiple layers they were very functional
for simple problems elegantly carried out but they
had a very very non neuromorphic backup which uh a
method for operation which i'll talk about very
briefly called back propagation as a learning rule
and as we will see back in this classical past
a book that i and my friends put together said
these might be more interesting if they were more
neuromorphic in the present of course artificial
neural nets due to the growth and processing power
of modern computers and due to much more subtle
and interesting design of the artificial neural
nets are can perform some extremely important
machine learning problems and so they are
enormously functional today but they're
they they still cannot be one to one matched
to what it is the brain does or how it does it
the future perfect that i list down here
it would be really nice to leverage our
understanding of neurons and circuits to be
able to build artificial neural nets that
were more neuromorphic and so enhance machine
learning and it also might be useful to think
about some of the very clever ways people are now
designing artificial neural nets as we contemplate
ways in which the brain does what what it does
so going back this is supposed to be historical
this is 1987. i took a ganglion i'd been working
on since the 1960s and i presented it on the
right as if it were a neural network but of course
it's biological instead of being arbitrary units
emulated in software or built with transistors
and capacitors these were real identified neurons
in a real ganglion of the marine snail eplisia
and i presented this at the first international
conference on neural networks just when the field
was beginning to get interesting and as you see it
was a multi-layer network with defined properties
also around then we had a meeting at woods hall
in which we this is the fanciful design for the
t-shirt for the meeting we thought we could link
biological and artificial neural networks
and look to see what their commonality
was and you can see the red biological
neurons in the lower left and the artificial
neural network units and connections in the
upper right coming out of something which
is a meld between a hippocampus and anaplysia
which were the uh subjects most often studied
in this context in 1989 and you see this was again
early this was the second volume of the journal
neural networks i proposed a testing and
artificial neural network learning rule
in a biological neural network it failed
spectacularly but it was still interesting
enough to be published thereby underscoring
the idea that artificial and biological neural
networks had some real fundamental differences i
was not the only one who began to point this out
from the field of neurobiology you can see
some names on the left the one up at the top
dr gordon shepherd published a paper in which he
pointed out some very very significant differences
between biological and artificial neural networks
and other investigators again in the 1980s listed
down below on the left contributed to ideas
for this birth of neuromorphic neural networks
even francis crick got into the act and he
published this commentary in nature at the
end of the 1980s and you can see in the center
the lower part of the center column he points
out that whatever it is artificial neural networks
do the brain is different in almost every respect
and that's francis quite elegantly pointing out
how far one has to go to be able to talk about to
linking the artificial and the biological neural
network so after this uh this flurry of interest
by neurobiologists in artificial nets and even
interest in the people who were purely developing
artificial nets in the brain i got together some
friends and we asked this question is a network of
neurons really a neural network we noted back then
that some features of artificial neural nets and
the biological networks of neurons those are the
bnns you've seen resembled one another but others
didn't now my co-authors then were leveraging a
ns to understand bnns in the hope of making the
artificial nets more neuromorphic and more capable
but in the intervening 27 years now we know much
more about biological nets and the sophisticated
artificial nets deep convolutional nets
long short term memory nets have become
much more useful so it's time to revisit
this and that's what i'm doing today i'm going
to ask some artificial neural network inspired
general questions about how biological neural
nets compute and up questions about whether
evolution has conserved some of the basics for
this back in 1993 my colleague eberhard fetz
pointed out in the context of a biological
net how artificial neural nets did things
in terms of excitatory and inhibitory connection
matrices which had variable strengths something
that sounds very much like the way biological nets
work the problem that we stressed in 1993 was that
artificial neural nets and their properties are
summarized by the diagrams on this slide and the
equations that accompany them they can biological
networks work a little bit like artificial nets
according to the scheme on the left that is they
take in inputs they sum it there's a non-linear
transform this is then transformed along an axon
in a forward direction from cell body to termini
and then there are connections made on still other
neurons and everything on the left is sort of
plausible in a biological context but on the right
artificial nets require back propagation of errors
and multi-layer back propagation
or local tuning of synapse strength
by global error signals or error signals many
many layers further up these were viewed quite
skeptically in 1993. as i'll show later
on the skepticism has been a little bit
reduced but the basic back propagation scheme
shown here on the right which i'm not going to
go into in detail seemed very different from
the way we thought neurons worked in 1995
now we should remember that evolution works
evolution designs neural networks neural
networks work and i'm also going to stress the
fact that neural networks process or compute
information of course they evolved to be able
to learn but what they are learning to do
is to perform pattern recognition to be able to
recognize say a piece of fruit from a predator
to classify many many different inputs to
make decisions on the back of it and to form
action patterns as a result of this
we know that the networks in our brain
and even in other animals and even in other
parts of our nervous system like the spinal cord
or the eye may be optimized for specif
specific features of the real world
because evolution found that to be efficient
so things like locality low dimensionality
relevance novelty those things may get more
attention from nervous systems than others
some biological neural networks and by
this i mean small networks composed of a
manageable number of neurons some of them do
things that we can understand integrators for
instance we can understand comparators some use
maximum entropy strategies for efficient coding
but in general we don't know how they work
that is we don't know what they're computing
or how they're computing it and that's motivation
for this work because if we did know that then
perhaps the ways in which our brains efficiently
do this computation and reduce error making use of
only the mechanisms that the laws of physics
and evolution make available to them could that
enhance the design of artificial neural networks
especially artificial neural networks that
we want to design to solve problems that are
similar or isomorphic to the ones that our
brains solve now i use the word computation and
and we probably don't think of our nervous systems
as computing and we may think of arithmetic for
instance is something that's very very artificial
that we can do but certainly our nervous systems
didn't evolve to do and so i'm just pointing out
that many uh lower organisms in addition to
people seem to be able to do computations
there are reports that that pigeons
can behaviorally show subtraction
understand subtraction and modify
their actions in a trained situation
according to carrying out even something as
simple as an insect honeybees can can use tags
for something that's greater than what they've one
greater than what they've seen before or one fewer
than what they've seen before and they can again
modify their actions by this so so nervous systems
even what we used to call primitive nervous
systems seem to be able to actually do computation
and of course i'm using the term in a much larger
sense than that i'm using it to mean processing
information but i find it striking that that that
computation itself counting is something that
nervous systems seem to be able to do now here's
a very famous slide that most of you are likely
to have seen before and this shows from the
laboratory from dan yemen's working in the
laboratory of jim dicarlo at mit some years ago
this shows similarities between the circuitry
that does processing in the ventral stream of
primate vision and that's shown up on the top
and an artificial neural network trained to
recognize people from photographs of those people
and what's striking about the
similarities is that in each case
these are composed of simple units neurons
up above and artificial units down below
there is a feed-forward organization to these
there are non-linear transforms and although
the two are very very different what is
striking about this is that at several
layers of both the real biological net and the
artificial net there are individual units and sets
of units that seem to have the same selectivity
for the very same pictures in the very same way
in different ways at different levels and the
maturity of being able to recognize an individual
based on information that is processed across the
multiple layers that also progresses in both the
biological net and the artificial net so this
reminds us that there are enough similarities
between what a multi-layer system can do to
make this an interesting and important question
even though the behavior at the individual levels
is very very different for the biological and for
the artificial system so let's ask ourselves
that's enough of an introduction let's ask
ourselves what is it that biological neural
networks are computing well i don't know
these are unanswered questions these are very
reductionist questions these are the simplest way
i can express it and one question is
what is it that brains are computing then
how if you know that how are those computations
actually implemented by neural circuitry
and what to me is the most interesting potential
question is the third one do these computations
form a small canonical set that is if evolution
has conserved as it has the basic properties
of neurons synapses glia across the animal kingdom
as well as the goals that nervous systems produce
is the next level the circuit level also
conserved and is there a small canonical set
of circuits or computations performed by this
circuit that one can identify comparatively
by looking at different parts say of a single
nervous system like the cortex or by looking
across nervous systems even perhaps to some of
those honeybees in applicia that i mentioned
earlier and then there's a fourth unanswered
question which is neurons are cells glia are
cells uh they make use of neurochemicals and which
of the many many properties that characterize
these cells that happen to be neurons are actually
the ones that are essential for computation
there's another question not listed here
which i i may touch on briefly which is how do
biological nets solve the curse of dimensionality
because they have far more parameters to adjust
than artificial neural nets do and i think
these really do qualify as some of those elusive
principles of neural science that we
would all like to be able to work out so
are these principles that i just showed you on
the last slide are they evolutionarily conserved
here you see the very very famous levels from
pat churchland and terry sanofsky from the
central nervous system up at the top down through
successively finer layers do we get down to the
individual molecules at the bottom and we should
look at what it is that evolution has conserved
okay sweeping up from the bottom molecularly
there's a very small number of essential proteins
and other molecules that are not sometimes
some of them are specific to neural function
some of them are available for general cell
biology but tend to be used in the same way
in nervous systems throughout the animal kingdom
looking up one layer there's a very small number
of excitatory and inhibitory synapses there are
very very few neurotransmitters and there's a
small conserved number conserved in sequence and
in structure of membrane proteins that help carry
out synaptic transmissions up above neurons look
very very different from one another in structure
but the number of basic types is very very small
enormous quantitative variation in the properties
of the neurons electrical anatomical functional
but but really they're qualitatively they're
all quite similar and the neurochemistry
is very very similar so but in between
in between at the network at the
layer of the network or the circuit
are the circuits really the micro circuits
and the computations and transforms that they
mediate are those similarly evolutionarily
conserved is there a small number of canonical
types up at the top which you can still see
the goals of the nervous system the componentry
whatever it is that nervous systems do in the
life of organisms that's similarly conserved
by evolution so it's an intriguing question to
see if this mid layer is also something that
ends up with a small number of canonical
properties and to repeat we're talking both about
the computations or transforms that are performed
and also the circuitry that performs them
so there is some complexity there certainly is
some variability especially to within the networks
but what is it that might be neuromorphically
essential this what's common to nervous
systems what's characteristic of nervous
systems that might inform our thinking
when we start asking these questions well
nervous systems have complex connectivity
it's more complex than that of artificial neural
nets which tend to be very very simple there
are three or four different ways in which they
come in which they are connected to one another
but in the the brain in brains in nervous systems
the connectivity is sparse as well as complex
there obviously are micro circuits that are
characteristic of different structures of the
brain that the circuitry looks different
but perhaps the functions that are being
performed are are are not so different we need to
study that there is extensive top-down signaling
in almost all nervous systems in addition to the
bottom-up ones we tend to think of from sensation
through computation to action now brains have many
many more neurons like artificial neural networks
artificial neural networks these days
tend to be deep with many many layers
but the brains tend to have fewer layers
than functional artificial neural networks
these days some of them are like wide rather
than deep artificial nets a subset of the top
and different parts of the brain and different
uh different nervous systems tend to be wider
or deeper again perhaps because they're
carrying out the functions in different ways
most artificial neural networks make very little
use of inhibition but the brain does require
inhibition and what's fascinating is within
a structure there's always a characteristic
percentage of neurons that are inhibitory but this
percentage varies widely it's two percent say in
something like the cerebellum up to 50 in some
other areas 20 percent in the cortex and the types
of inhibitory mechanisms and the effects they
perform on on neurons very greatly those are again
tuned biological nets brains are very very
stochastic that is if you look trial to trial
in an artificial neural network if you feed
it the same input you're very likely to get
the same output each time this is not true of
brains at the cellular or synaptic level and
that stochasticity is fascinating and may itself
have a computational role and of course biological
networks make use of plastic synapses that is
the efficacy of the synapse changes over time
now artificial nets have plastic synapses
or variable strength connectivity but that's
usually only modified in a training period and
once training is complete those tend to be fixed
and maintained this is not true of the brain and
and that's for the reason that we and our brains
have to keep learning at all times and there is no
time when we can expect the brain to be stable and
fully wired up with no changes in the future now
any system that learns has to have learning rules
any system that computes has to have algorithms
to perform the computations but again these are
things that surprisingly are imperfectly
understood and we really need to get better
of these that in order to carry
out these questions so how to begin
well if there's a conserved property of
nervous systems that's useful for computation
then perhaps we can ask what's
common to all nervous systems
and here's a list of some of the things this
expands on some of the stuff i said earlier
nervous systems fire irregularly the
synapses are stochastic and plastic
essentially all nervous systems process
information in two different ways through digital
spikes or action potentials and through analog
or graded post-synaptic potentials and they all
have in between these two a non-linear transform
and so one question is is there a neuromorphic
computational advantage to this there certainly
is for artificial neural nets because artificial
neural nets that don't have a non-linearity
built into them at every level at every layer
don't work very well one thing that's striking to
a cell biologist is that neurons post development
are very very long lived is this persistence
essential non-neuronal cell types aren't like
that they turn over perfectly happily so your red
blood cells or your bone or your skin turns over
quite frequently without any change but for some
reason neurons don't what's the advantage there
also neural circuitry leverages very high
fan in and fan out the selective balancing
of inhibition i mentioned a moment ago and so
this forms a dynamic assembly but it's it's
stable at any given moment and it's really quite
remarkable that evolution can provide dynamism
and constant change while keeping the system
stable another characteristic of nervous system
is that an enormous amount of processing is
done by local nets and the local nets process
information but they're modulated or coordinated
by long fibers from other local nets and i list
here some of the things that may be made possible
by this but i want to stress that the connectivity
the long distance connections come from the bottom
up which seems logical but they also come from the
top down in the nervous system and they're also
lateral and without this condistant connectivity
constantly informing the local processing net of
how it should be doing its computation it doesn't
work and again neurons vary in their connectivity
their excitatory inhibitory balance how they
integrate and so on so brains do not have a single
kind of processing unit okay so these are some
possible candidates for computational essentials
but there are also properties that are common
to all neurons that are cell biological they're
important for function but they're unlikely to be
computational essentials and i list some of the
basic cell biology without this the neurons will
die but these are not computational these
are just keeping the system working so it
can make use of those comp special computational
properties and there's also a lot of diversity
within and among nervous systems and i'm going
to very briefly show this because this is not
an audience of neuroscientists different synapses
and the neurons that make the synapses are tuned
in different ways the structure of neurons
vary and the circuits are tuned what the
synapses do where on the cells the synapses are
formed all of these things are quite specific
the dendrites of the nervous system are
quite specialized those are the inputs
and i think these are drawings from santiago
ramone cajal the great spanish neuroanatomist
assembled by my friends kristen harris
and john fiala to show differences here
and the dendrites are the parts that are shown in
the gray arrow and above and a little bit below
and you see on the left they can be very very
small and selective and take tight inputs from
the immediate area in the middle this hippocampal
pyramidal cell with an extensive dendritic tree
is actually sampling the space in which it's
located it's only getting input from about three
to five percent of the neurons that it could reach
with those dendrites so it's quite selective as to
the connections it's making and on the right the
cerebellar purkinje cell has this giant sheet that
can get hundreds of thousands of inputs and this
one is indiscriminate in the sense that it makes
a connection to every fiber that comes anywhere
near it so the way in which neurons compute
depends on the circuits in which they are placed
and here are some classic examples on the left
this is the canonical excitatory cell arrangement
in cerebral cortex showing how pyramidal cells
make connections to other pyramidal cells and
different parts in the middle the cerebral
cortex has several kinds of interneurons and these
different interneurons are shown making specific
connections on parts of pyramidal cells or of
other interneurons on the right the circuitry
in the cerebellum and i showed you the purkinje
cell dendrites just a slide or so ago this
combines both excitatory and inhibitory cells and
it's a much simpler circuit but it's one whose
purpose still remains incompletely understood
and there are several different candidates for
the computation being performed by this so one
question that we also need to think about if we're
going to be looking for canonical connections
is what isn't common to all nervous systems
so given this diversity there are features found
in some nervous systems but not in others if there
are reductionist computational essentials they're
unlikely to be one of the ones listed on this
slide so we do not have all-purpose neurons or one
fixed balance for excite excitation and inhibition
nor is it merely an emergent property of having
large numbers of neurons nor is a neuron a simple
atomistic object like in artificial neural
networks because neurons vary widely and
some are quite complex single neurons and able to
process information and neuronal firing is highly
variable i totally told you that to a fixed
stimulus the nervous system never responds
exactly the same way like heraclitus's
river and here is a stereotyped stimulus
being delivered and these are recordings from six
electrodes for the ten different trials here and
you'll notice that for each of the six electrodes
the ten different trials show very very different
results now this variability may be intentional
there may be deterministic input that we don't
know about it may be noise the very presence
of noise may aid calculation we don't know
now here's a fundamental problem that we have we
can record from thousands of neurons in biological
neural networks this is already 10 years old and
that was showing reliable recording of 200 neurons
or so but these multi-electrode techniques and
these arrays have gotten even better and we can
now record from thousands and thousands of neurons
but we can't predict the firing of thousands of
neurons if we understood what i said was the
problem how do nervous systems compute and what
is the circuitry that does the computation then we
could predict the operation of the nervous system
now this is easy for electrical circuits with
thousands of components but it's not true for
more than a handful of neurons and even for those
it's not true for more than a handful of seconds
also we can simulate exemplar nervous
systems artificial ones resembling the brain
with very fixed tuned parameter values but
this doesn't work for real specific neurons
or circuits and this is because individual neural
and synaptic parameters vary in ways we can't
easily measure and there are too many of them to
model exactly and this raises another question the
brain developmentally selects and tunes parameters
other than synaptic strength but we don't know how
the slow process during development is the brain's
first credit assignment problem credit assignment
being the problem of knowing what to change deep
within a network to get a desired result to learn
and then tuning individual synaptic strength
during adult life classical plasticity is
the brain's second credit assignment problem
so how do biological nets perform these two
credit assignment problems neural networks
need to do it to function to stabilize and
to tune synaptic weights any neural network
does artificial neural networks do it most
famously by multi-layer back propagation but
i already told you that's non-neuromorphic and
many groups have listed proposed alternatives to
these again here are the two different properties
i also should mention some clinical relevance
the developmental selection form of of uh credit
assignment is disrupted and the result for that
are some very early auto developmental disorders
secondly there are the individual tuning that
is altered in later onset neurodevelopmental
disorders that show up say between the ages of
17 and 25 as a fascinating footnote at the bottom
there's one transcription factor called mecp2
which manifests early as a gain of function defect
for that first problem but as a loss of function
it affects the second problem here so the same
molecule may be involved in both of these so here
are some of those alternatives i i talked about
here you know the biological neural network local
circuits may be pre-programmed for plasticity
there's something called synapse tagging that i
won't have time to get to is there a local process
or a global excitatory inhibitory balance that
can do this do astrocytes receive global signals
and adjust local some people have proposed a
solution called neuroevolution for this i don't
have the time to go into them and i'm going to
zoom through the slides that present it here's
a question of a neuron that makes two different
connections the neuron is shown in red between
two green neurons here and in fact tagging of
one output site rather than another can mean that
that is functional and will change with a global
signal whereas the other one won't there is in
uh the possibility of glial cells the glial
cells are shown here in blue the neurons
are shown in this tan color presynaptic endings
on the top a little bit of the postsynaptic neuron
below for each of these four diagrams and the
neurotransmitters in this case glutamate the
excitatory gaba the inhibitory neurotransmitters
are recycled for further synaptic transmission
through the glial cells and glial cells may make
more connections than the neurons and may receive
signals to control synaptic strength and i'm
going to skip over this which shows basically
the same sort of thing we saw below so many
groups have proposed various neuromorphic
suggestions linking artificial and
biological neural nets for credit assignment
other people have reported properties of bnns that
might be computationally useful or essential and
as these examples scroll majestically by as we
go from the upper layers down to the lower layers
this simply shows that there are a large number
of potential candidates for an evolutionarily
conserved mechanism mechanisms for
computation and mechanisms for uh
for um for credit assignment i want
to just talk about one very briefly
uh the first one here which is shown in red
this is recent work from chuck stevens lab
at the salk showing that in several different
sensory systems in mammals and invertebrates
maximum entropy coding encodes and decodes
the largest number of possible choices that
the nervous system has to make given the number
of cells used for the task it's highly efficient
my enthusiasm means that i've run late so i can't
talk about it but here's a credit assignment one
this expands on what i saw about astrocytes
even including the control of non-linearities
in addition to the amount of neurotransmitter
that's been advanced by a couple of labs
i'm not going to talk about the fly odor coding
but i refer you to recent work from this the lab
of cf stevens for this instead i want to finish
by telling you about the n-cubed project here
for looking for neuromorphic computation now
i pulled these five books from my bookshelf
six books sorry uh five which can do something and
the sixth which can't they all present circuits
but the one on brain micro circuits gordon shepard
and sten grilners the arrows pointing to it
is not like the others it's the only one where the
anatomy the function and the connectivity of many
micro circuits are laid out in beautiful detail
but not the computations they perform why is this
so why can the electronic circuit books do this
they can take the circuit on the left and predict
from that the function as shown on the right
or they can take the pattern of activity shown
on the right and reverse engineer the circuit
that's doing that called system identification
so they can do that but we can't so our
neural circuits identifiable in the same way
and as it says here electronic ones are the third
bullet point says that there are a few neural
circuit operations or calculations i mentioned
one or two of these earlier weighted summation
leaky integration gated various patterns of
inhibition lateral inhibitions surround inhibition
isomorph a non-isomorphic anisomorphic surround
inhibition which gives you direction sensitivity
response sharpening from surround
inhibition gain control winner take all
persistence of a signal delay lines attractors
even some predictors non-linear analog to digital
and digital log to anal digital to analog
converters we know neural circuits do this
but if we're thinking in terms of electronics
where are say the half adders or where is
something that can demodulate a signal from a
carrier now one possibility is we can't detect
other than the elementary building blocks
and find the serious functional circuits
well maybe stochastic firing is a com confound
and that makes input output analyses hard to do
now one question is are neurons just too diverse
or too specialized to form canonical circuits
all neurons are variants of only a few basic types
and this is also true of electronic components
so on the left is a listing of some hippocampal
inhibitory neurons there are many different kinds
shown there but they all perform the
same basic function and this is just like
the many mosfets on the right not quite
interchangeable you can't plug one in for
the other but all working the same way and all
covered by the same uh symbol some people say
you know i'm advocating consideration and search
for potential evolutionarily conserved mechanisms
but maybe that isn't the case maybe all
the circuits and computations are just
evolutionarily ad hoc and there is no general
circuitry nor canonical no general theory nor
canonical circuitry evolution just builds ad hoc
and it's different everywhere or computability may
just be an emergent property of any circuitry
that sums and transforms so do we care some
people say they don't care whether it does it
or not i care and and so at uh the society for
neuroscience symposium about a year and a quarter
ago where i introduced this topic i asked the
hundred or so attendees what they thought and the
voting among the neuroscientists was ten to one
in favor of canonical circuits or algorithms so i
want to wrap up with what i want to do about this
many different labs work on this problem but what
i'm proposing is not something that any single
lab can do to answer a general question requires
collegial parallel efforts by many investigators
using different techniques in several preparations
and so what we need to do is to get together
we're going to be planning a multi-day neuro
match meeting of this to get this started and
we'll know that this is going to work if at least
half the people we invite say well i'm already
doing that or already solved that problem and then
once we get people aboard this what we want to be
able to do is to encourage funding agencies to
support adding explorations of computational
capabilities to the ongoing research from many
of those labs and those different preparations
and of course because we're forward thinking we
think all data code algorithms and so on should be
open source and freely available and this would
help launch this field and allow other funding
agencies to decide so you're hearing something
that's just at the beginning of a new idea and
here are some of the people who contributed
to this at symposia in 2019 and in 2020
for this of course the sfn symposium was not just
a few months ago it was a year and a few months
ago because we didn't have one meeting in in
2020 but all of these people contributed to this
and i'd like to thank those groups who've
collegially helped build this idea along
and now i'm ready for questions dan thank you
so much for that uh overview of neural networks
and what kind of computing they do and this is
just clearly a an interesting challenge which is
it's interesting from the context of of
data science which is you know so often
deals with thinking about how to statistically
analyze uh systems for example in this case you're
really trying to take it to the next level say
perhaps using the knowledge you gain through a
data science approach to inform how you might
create synthetic models of biological systems
so this is very pleased that you were able to
present this to us one of the things which one of
our our uh participants kind of raises a question
i have the same question myself is that very often
these neural networks the the whole the goal it's
claimed is oh pattern recognition we want to be
able to recognize patterns but really is that what
we really want to do all the time or really are we
trying to understand the foundational properties
of these biological systems and i think you're
a fan of the latter and not the former and i
also want to kind of ask in that same context is
as a result of that do these artificial versus
biological neural networks do they pass something
resembling any kind of a turing test that we're
aware of well okay so so so the first question is
is well people say that these networks are good
at pattern recognition or pattern identification
because that's how they test them right and i
think something that isn't i didn't say explicitly
but i probably should is what you think a system
is doing depends upon what question you asked it
but i don't know what it was that evolution
designed the system to do we know what we can
do but we don't know how but we can do it from
introspection we can do it by observing others
by either others of our species or experimental
animals but that doesn't tell us what's actually
being done and and the purpose of say of of having
a uh a group of different investigators working in
different preparations is to say for someone to
say well i think that what the the micro circuit
that i'm doing is computing is the following
and can somebody test out that idea on their
preparation and see if that's something similar to
it so that's how we start looking for what might
be a small number of canonical computations
so i don't know what it's what it's there for
now the other question uh you weren't specific
about the artificial versus biological and and
the touring test i i showed an example the classic
ones are unfortunately ones that are used for
pattern recognition and for pattern discrimination
those are the ones that mimic the visual system
and and and that is a form of turing test
in that you can give a primate or you can
give an artificial neural net the same inputs
and allow each one will make the same mostly
the same selections and discriminations so are
you willing to accept that as as a touring test
what we're talking about of course is
something at a very simple fundamental level
and so i think the turing test you want is to
be able to identify a a computation that you
think a a network of 80 or 100 neurons is
performing and then you should be able to feed it
inputs and predict what the output is that is not
quite a turing test that is a test of a model and
i think that's as close as you're going to get
when we're talking about phenomena at this level
you know it's another thing is as you were
presenting and talking about some of these kind
of foundational building blocks the the the rules
or the the the kind of the behaviors of these
neurons in these systems i'm reminded that it's
been 50 years since conway's game of life kind
of emerged on the scene and many of us who are of
a certain age monkeyed around with those simple
rules uh between neighboring cells in a network
to try to produce interesting behaviors out of
very simplistic rules and i'm kind of curious if
some of those be not of course the same rules but
are would you hope that a similar sort of you know
three five rules might be uh underlying what we
see in very complex systems uh well yeah it's even
better than that because conway's game of life is
a special case and a late special case of cellular
automata exactly and the cellular automata that
were first looked at in the 1904 and early 1950s
by uh johnny van neumann and others were they were
consciously thinking about nervous systems and
computing at the same time and they wanted to
do their their first look at cellular automata
was actually to build a touring machine and i
think they they had one with what was it 39 rules
and and that could compute absolutely anything
and so they could build a turing machine out of
cellular automata but again this was a time when
nothing was known about the brain in the terms
that we know it now and the the synthesis between
cellular automata computers and nervous systems
doing processing has been with us for what is
now uh almost 70 years so so the the the links
are intriguing the game of life is just a very
very simple thing this it would be great fun if
we discovered that some of neural development
i mean if you think about this in terms of an
electronic analogy the brain is wired up from
a parts kit these days electronic devices are all
three-dimensional and you lay down transistors
and capacitors and resistors in multiple layers
which is similar to the way neurons go in the
brain are excitatory inputs come from the neurons
come from the subventricular zone our inhibitory
ones fly in from the ganglionic eminence just
at the right time from a different parts bin
and then they assemble themselves and that's
part of that first credit assignment problem
that i talked about here so there are always going
to be engineering questions it would be fun if
some of the principles used for those inhibitory
neurons to make some of those connections
could be shown to be in some ways isomorphic
to some of the rules that cellular automata
use i have no idea if that's true or not but it
shows you how thinking about the brain from this
perspective can cause different people and i
hope somebody listening to this is is taking
notes saying that would be an interesting problem
to work on how this can inform uh what you know
what what work should be done one final question
for you dan what role does data science play in
achieving some of the goals of what you described
for it's essential and i should have made this
explicit because when i talk about people saying
making comparisons from laboratory to laboratory
that requires the easy exchange of data you can
say this is what my neuron does my my neural
network does and does your neural network do
this and that's not possible without effortlessly
taking the algorithm and the data extending it and
and you and i jack worked on this years ago for
the human brain project when we tried doing some
of the first fundamental rules for data exchange
for the neurosciences and and without that sort
of effort what i propose would not be possible
well dan thank you so much for sharing this is
so fun this is so thought provoking i could go
all day but uh i want to thank you so much for uh
sharing this with us this was really inspiring and
i hope that our audience was inspired as well
um thank you so much uh thank you everybody for
who joined us and um enjoy your weekend we'll
see you next week thank you thanks so long all